welcome to this blitz game video long
long I don't know what do we have the
group felt I going with my Bishop f4
line that's my my line that i recently
studied night h5 what is this nah come
on you're not telling me that this is
possible so what can i do now i can take
d5 and give the mechanic with the night
and i can check with the pawn now i
think this should be ok actually night
takes I'm not so sure about he has
neither 494 see five or so it just just
just doesn't look like any kind of
compensation I will see am I going to
get d5 back I'll play Bishop c4
night directly tries for activity and
that's interested interesting actually
it might be time that I can take right
and go D fire okay that was more
interesting than other continuations
definitely it doesn't look like it
should be be anything but it is better
than many other lines so if I go a three
is going bishops III ready or okay I'm
protecting this first bishop at five
maybe
interesting
should be three there's Bishop f5 maybe
should be three this Bishop f5
hmm ok so I have to grab stuff check if
he could be chicks 95 this Bishop see
sex and you just lose this material so
is he going to age who also I don't know
Maureen 85 now I have no idea what a
what a mess hmm so here I can also play
C 4 and s position here besides taking
but Bishop c4 looks quite normal only
leaves but I think he has to go to a six
now
yeah interesting them I can do normal
stuff y or queen d for may be preventing
night c 5 mm I don't know I think that
looks interesting and also if i go on
idea three instead he might have Bishop
g4 with a somewhat somewhat annoying pin
okay so we developed with a three or
something our castle I mean he can do 95
no sew 95 an idea for 96 or a now come
on let's guess the first always like to
have things tidy I could have taken a
seven actually would have been quite
interesting okay but this is not the
answer just prepare c4 here if he takes
d5 property one will win the peace I
think I might have we should be several
actually he might have pushed should be
somewhere
I should have calculated this better
that was just sloppy I was just very
sloppy plane okay well night be 625
still looks pretty good e 64 there
should be seven minutes out okay I'm
still okay yeah but keep the peace so
what here Queen a seven just taking just
taking stuff come on let's take that all
right maybe you can take it for with the
Queen actually
hmm roop t41 is interesting let's do
that there's also this possible tactic
with kicking 1g5 if he goes like I know
to f6 off so i can double take on d5
because there's p8 hanging so his choice
is somewhat limited now yeah I think
after so okay let's do this maybe 90
form trying to provoke him to take on b3
which will probably not happen you know
he won't and straighten he does
straighten my pawn structure okay didn't
even remotely thought that this would be
playable but maybe he gets enough power
to play against my pawns this is
possible like this okay can go in there
g3 maybe check time are KFC SC SC I
cannot go looks you one looky one is not
good okay so you can take that and I'm
going to march with the beep on just
claiming that map youporn it's dangerous
yeah that's the usual way to do it you
should stop the Casa at the first
possible moment five- get down my king
is far more active
that's critical for black I think I'm in
very good shape because of my active
King Leck resins and that's a pretty
rash decision but maybe maybe I'm really
close to winning but what is the best
probably him running quickly with the
King like this this is this and now move
the rook somewhat somehow like he also
and okay one mad it's not lost now I
mean it'sit's good chances for white but
not lost yeah I really played this not
too well because the opening position is
certainly about winning night h5 I don't
believe that move and what is this the
computer actually wants to play Bishop
b5 Wow there should be fire which kind
of means that night h5 isn't that
terrible but the compounds play c6 now
ok about black can not take that much is
clear and this is also not really great
there's some not electric we should be
five I mean if he does something simple
I mean this this is probably better for
wider well so this isn't any good I can
of Y and takes this is in fact good for
black amazing
with Bishop f5 yeah I was I wasn't
exactly sure what I were playing and
said I have to admit after day three is
going CA them black has huge pressure
here this I mean this wasn't entirely
clear check this this and nighty too is
good for black but this is losing almost
yeah I thought this is very strong move
yes this move I didn't see that one I
just saw lines like what I did see is I
saw stuff like this like 185 this is
this this is a time that I pinning up
here but I didn't see the this strike
and losers for example amazing where
this isn't working at all right and now
there's a strong 8 castles this and no
95 wins for 94 and 96 so this this
wasn't so great f5 is strong yeah I
briefly thought about it but I didn't
yeah i saw this actually but i was
thinking he can probably go here and
here for 25 okay so that was very strong
a fire that basically wins the whole
thing it's plus 3 okay i took that and
now things are cut off from easy but
yeah that surprised me a great deal but
okay engine wants to do this why exactly
I have because this I've got this okay
well I only saw that this end game is
good it's just a question if does it win
for white or not drawing margin is
pretty high but I just saw that and went
for it them with not much time okay I
was interesting thanks for watching